on November the 16th of 1957 officers in
Plainfield Wisconsin walked into one of
the most gruesome crime scenes in
history on a remote farm they found a
house decorated with the body parts of
women there were waste paper baskets
made from heads chairs upholstered with
human skin masks made from tripled faces
it was a house of horrors unlike
anything the state had seen before and
it was all the work of one man
Ed Gein a local part-time handyman and
full-time weirdo loner
Ed Gein was also a cannibal serial
killer who'd go down in history as the
butcher of Plainfield the inspiration
for Norman Bates in psycho Leatherface
in the Texas Chainsaw Massacre and
Buffalo Bill in Silence of the Lambs
Dean's crimes were so horrific that his
specter still haunts the nightmares of
present-day America but who really was
this monster and how did he become quite
so disturbed well today we're taking you
on a journey into the mind of the
original psycho
[Music]
from the moment Edward Theodore Gein
came into the world on August the 27th
1906 he was destined for an awful life
the second son of George Philip and
Augustine young Edwards childhood home
was haunted by the twin demons of
alcohol and religious fanaticism father
George Philip was a crippling alcoholic
whose tiny self-worth couldn't even be
detected by the most powerful electron
microscope mother Augusta was a hardcore
religious not who saw sin and filth
everywhere alongside his older brother
Henry young Edward taught that the city
of La Crosse was a haven of sodomites
and harlots they were also taught that
they were completely worthless when
Augusta wasn't verbally abusing the boys
she was bullying her drunken husband
despite this saw maybe perhaps because
of it it came to idolize her in 1915 or
custom moved the family from the leafy
Sodom of the Cross to the quiet Gomorrah
of Plainfield Wisconsin a tiny town in
the heart of deer hunting country
Plainfield can be summed up by three
adjectives flash empty and anonymous
unless of course you're August again in
which case those adjectives were sinful
sinful and even more sinful from their
secluded farmhouse on the edge of town
or Guster preached the boys about evil
she taught them that women were
creatures who corrupted men and defiled
Christ the only time ed and Henry were
let out of her sight was to go to school
although they were forbidden from making
any friends not that this made much
difference Edie was intelligent a
feminist and kind of weird-looking in
short he was a bully's dream come true
after teenage years marred by endless
beatings ed reg waited school and fled
back to Augustus called embrace he never
socialized again on April the 1st 1940
God played his cruelest April Fool's
joke on all of the family George Philip
Dean was carried off by a heart attack
leaving his now 30-something sons all
alone with that domineering mother it
was even worse than you're probably
imagining if pre dead husband or ghost
who was a fanatic post dead husband or
Guster was a flaming lunatic she forced
it into ed and Henry skulls that all
women were evil incarnate so that the
entire world was against them when Henry
tried to escape her clutches starting a
relationship with a
a mother of two in Plainfield she
denounced him as well the good older
brother to the end Henry tried to
convince ed to side with him against
their mother sadly though it had already
chosen his side in winter of 1944 a fire
broke out on the furthest reaches of the
Gein farm the fire brigade went
screaming over in their tracks to find
ed in a state of agitation claiming his
old brother had vanished in the blaze
after a long search through the
smoke-filled woods police found Henry
lying face down a savage blow to the
back of the head
the coroner recorded death by smoke
inhalation and Ed was never even
questions when news of Henry's death
reached Augusta the old woman suffered a
massive stroke that left her badly
disabled finally after nearly four
decades of existence ed Gein's wish it
had come true he was now completely
alone with his beloved and awful mother
[Music]
the next year was one of almost complete
isolation from late 1944 to the end of
1945 as oh Augusta lived alone seeing
almost no one they were doing nothing
except cultivating their already toxic
relationship until it reached Chernobyl
levels of radioactivity it was a year of
optimism in the rest of the country
though a year in which a war was won on
two continents and young men returned
home to Cheers
but out on their farm in Plainfield all
of this passed ed under rust by indeed
the only significant thing that happened
to them that year was when Augusta made
a rare trip outside with Edie - my straw
from a man named Smith when they reached
Smith's house the duo witnessed him
beating a dog to death while an unknown
woman begged him to stop seeing this
Augusta became livid not because she was
watching an innocent creature suffer but
because the mystery woman was not
Smith's wife became Augustus stepped up
her teaching stared that all females
were guilty of lust mother her teachings
lasted much longer though on December
the 29th 1945 a second stroke carried
Augusta off to her eternal reward
suddenly alone 39 year-old Ed did the
only thing he knew how he sealed off for
Gustus room preserving it exactly as his
mother had left it then he shut up and
boarded all but two rooms in there
creaking house and slowly he descended
into madness as 19:46 rumbled by Ed Gein
became hooked on
red horror novels and pornography email
ordered books on Nazi medical
experiments and female anatomy and he
began teaching himself taxidermy finally
in 1947 something in Ed Gein snapped
he began robbing the graves of women who
were buried in the Plainfield cemetery
digging up the bodies by the dead of
night removing their hearts heads
genitals and intestines before returning
them to their crypts much later after
his arrest
Ed Gein would say that he went to the
cemetery in a daze that he had visions
of grave robbing but he never thought he
actually went through with it
the record though it says otherwise
today it's estimated the Gein robbed the
graves of over 40 women from cemeteries
all across the state by the 1950s he was
no longer even returning the bodies to
their tombs instead he drags the bodies
of these unknown sisters mothers
daughters and wives back to his remote
farmhouse and practice taxidermy on them
patiently learning his craft
despite this private madness Dean still
managed to semi function in public he
took old handyman jobs around Plainfield
in order to survive and even
occasionally got work as a babysitter to
show his gratitude he would give his
sometime employers packages of meat that
he called venison given what we know now
it does seem rather likely than what was
in those parcels was probably not
venison nope as 1954 dawns the nearly 50
year old Dean was now a prolific grave
robber likely cannibal and taxidermist
of human skin but there's one thing that
he wasn't just yet he wasn't yet a
serial killer
despite the hot-blooded likely murder of
Henry 10 years earlier again hadn't
graduated to the sort of cold-blooded
premeditated slaughter that made guys
like Ted Bundy and Jeffrey Dahmer so
famous sadly though that last to be it
was about to be broken
no one knows for sure how many people Ed
Gein killed he never confessed and the
state was unwilling to spend much money
on covering his gruesome crimes as such
there are some who think Dean may have
begun his murder spree prior to 1954
certainly he's been linked to many
Wisconsin missing person cases although
it's also possible that he's simply
become a useful scapegoat for any
unsolved murder but there's no ambiguity
about what happens on the 8th of
December 1954 that cold winter's night
Dean travelled to Pine Grove some ten
miles north of Plainfield he walked into
the local tavern where Mary Hogan worked
she was a middle-aged woman who looked
not unlike or gasta Dean shot and killed
Hogan and dragged her corpse out into
the snow he loaded her onto a sledge and
took her back to his farmhouse there he
shot her off with an axe and turned her
body parts into furniture
Hogan's murder it marked a major step
the guid but it wasn't the most truly
disturbing thing that had yet done by
the winter of 1954 games activities in
his lonely farmhouse had crossed into
almost demonic territory and as at this
point that I'll probably want to warn
you that the next section is not really
for the faint of heart so I'm not gonna
blame you if you do actually want to
turn off and watch something else right
now but with that in mind let's continue
the things game did the bodies he stole
it almost defies comprehension he sawed
off the tops of woman's severed heads to
turn their skulls into soup bowls II
stuffed their faces and hung them on
walls like hunting trophies beneath his
beds the butcher of Plainfield kept a
box of human noses alongside a box of
female genitals there's also rumors that
two of these severed vulvas had to
belong to girls below the age of 15
perhaps even more perversely Gein use
people's bodies to tailor his own
clothes there are credible stories of
police finding a belt made of human
flesh at games house buckles with human
nipples there are legs turned into
tights and corsets that are fashioned
from skin freakiest of all eddying took
the torso of one woman and turned it
into a tans jagged complete with a heavy
pair of breasts on moonlit night she
would wear it alongside a mask of skin
and danced around outside the cold blue
night of the Moon casting strange
shadows
on his twirling and mutilated form after
he was caught Dean would tell
investigators that it always secretly
wanted to be a woman but judging from
what we know of gheens crimes in his
victims it seems more likely that he
secretly wanted to be one woman his
mother over the next three years gheens
madness agreements silence way from the
eyes of plain films residents in the
cemetery the corpses of large
middle-aged women continued to disappear
their empty tombs unnoticed by their
blissfully ignorant families finally as
winter settled over Wisconsin wants
Morgan's demons they got the better of
him on November the 16th 1957 58
year-old Bernice worden was opening up
her hardware store in Plainfield when
Dean stepped inside and shot her debt
with the town nearly empty for the start
of hunting season Gein was able to sneak
wardens body out his car and drive her
back to his farm unnoticed he had big
plans for his latest victim plans that
would utilize all of his dubious skills
little did he know that the woman's body
already cooling in the back of his car
would be the one that ended his reign of
terror ah November the 15th Frank warden
decided to drop by his mom's hardware
store in the center of Plainfield a
sheriff's deputy Frank was trained to
notice people acting suspiciously and
there were a few people in town who
acted quite as suspiciously as plain
Fields resident weirdo Ed Gein the day
that Frank stopped in on his mom he
noticed Keane lurking around the store
at the time
Frank pushed it from his mind but 24
hours later it was back at the forefront
it was 5:00 p.m. on November the 16th
and Bernice worden she was missing
unlocking her store Frank found a blonde
slick of blood leading to the crisp snow
outside the last name written in the
register of sales was Ed Gein it was now
around eight hours since ghena shot
Bernice worden dead and carted her body
away but Frank was only acting on a
justified hunch when he called up the
station and asked them to investigate
the killer in the back of Frank's minds
there doubtless must have been a flicker
of hope that his mother was still alive
if that thought had ever existed it was
about to be extinguished in the most
brutal way possible
shortly after Frank's called Plainfield
police arrested Ed Gein as he was coming
out of a grocery store
handyman acted confused like he did
what was going on but it was too late
for games the play it was over all the
remains was its grisly do anymore that
night police carried out a raid on beans
farm in the freezing darkness they first
searched the barn what they found there
would set the tenor for the rest of the
night but east wardens corpse was
hanging upside down from a beam
completely gutted and its head missing
so badly had she been mutilated that
many of the officers initially thought
that her body was that of an animal
inside the house things already got
worse the farmhouse ed once shared with
Augusta and Henry had decayed into a
toxic swamp refuse littered the floors
while fat bloated flies crawled across
every surface on the stove Bernice
Worden's Hart and sat on a metal pan
ready for cooking human organs they
filled the freezer in a paper bag the
head of Mary Hogan grinned up the
investigators now little more than a
rotting skull you were ready know what
else they found their furniture made
from skin the mounted heads the female
bodies chopped and torn apart with blind
hatred finally just past 4:00 a.m. on
the morning of November the 17th someone
found binney's wardens head wrapped in a
bloodied sack twine had been hammered
into her skull he later admitted that it
intended to use it as a decoration
according to the book deviance by Harold
Schechter Wisconsin police officer
archly was so disturbed by what he saw
that night that he beat Dean's head
against a brick wall until the monster
confessed to the murders within months
Lee would be dead of a heart attack
killed his friends said by the memories
of that horrific night after Jean was
taken into custody he remarked casually
that he had no idea how many people had
killed Arizona when police searched
Plainfield cemetery and found so many
empty graves that they came to believe
warden and Hogan with the only victims
on the day after is arrest on November
the 18th 1957
Ed Gein awoke to find himself a
celebrity his story it gripped America
the papers carried lurid details of his
house of horrors
Gorp as they came from across the state
and beyond to get a look at the scene of
his crimes rather this was the age of
American innocence the economy it was
okay the middle class was expanding and
the optimism of the post-war years it
was still lingering in such a society ed
Gein's crimes they seemed even more
sensational the fascination was helped
along by the media that December ed
goons home would appear on the covers of
both life and time on November the 21st
Dean was hauled before was sharra County
Court he entered a plea of not guilty by
reason of insanity it didn't take long
for the state of Wisconsin to decide
that the feeling was mutual
in January of 1958 Dean was judged
mentally unfit to stand trial he was
detained at Wisconsin's Central State
Hospital for the criminally insane this
was the start of an incarceration that
would last for the rest of his life and
perhaps his story it would have ended
there were not for a very American twist
one of the Wisconsinites
avidly following Gunes trial was the
Milwaukee pulp writer Robert Bloch
fascinated by games creepy relationship
with his mother Bloch decided to
incorporate into the novel that he was
working on and this was a little book
called psycho in blocks vision handyman
Ed Gein became Norman Bates owner of the
Bates Motel when the book debuted in
1959 it caused a sensation barely a year
had passed before the legendary director
Alfred Hitchcock brought the rights and
transformed it into a movie if Ed Gein
was aware of his growing celebrity he
didn't show it at Central State Hospital
the countable serial killer gained a
reputation of being mild-mannered he
worked as a carpenter then as a medical
orderly people found him polite and even
kind after 10 years Dean was finally
declared competent to stand trial on
November the 7th 1968 he was tried for
the murder of Bernice worden
interestingly the state didn't bother to
prosecute Dean for Mary
Hogan's death it was thought that it
would waste too much money and that one
murder conviction would be enough still
Dean freely confessed to the crime
one week later on November the 14th Dean
was found guilty of first-degree murder
it was almost exactly 11 years
to the day that it shot Bernice worden
in cold blood and mutilated her body for
his own gratification faced with such a
crime you might think that the jury
recommended gain for the electric chair
but that didn't happen
Dean was found to have been insane at
the time of wardens death and he was
recommitted to Central State Hospital
and that was kind of that and Dean did
almost nothing of consequence for the
rest of his life in 1974 he petitioned
to be freed stirring up a media frenzy
but his case was denied and the
newspapers moved on this was the year of
Watergate what was one demented serial
killer stacked against the high crimes
and misdemeanors of men in high office
but while Dean the man was fading into
obscurity gained the legend it was only
growing in 1974 tow paper released a
low-budget flick there was as horrific
for audiences as psycho had been in 1960
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre drew on Ed
Gein's crimes to create the character of
Leatherface the chainsaw wielding serial
killer he wears a mask of human skin nor
would Hooper be the only one to take
inspiration from the butcher of
Plainfield Thomas Harris would draw from
the same well when creating the serial
killer Buffalo Bill for the 1988 book
Silence of the Lambs by then though the
man who'd inspired all of those stories
he was long gone on July the 26th 1984
Ed Gein breathed his last in Mendota
Mental Health Institute had been carried
off by lung cancer aged 77 in a ghoulish
twist his body was interned in the very
cemetery that it robbed so many times
some 30 years earlier in 1991 the film
adaptation of Silence of the Lambs
became only the third movie in history
to win all big five Oscars although
again is never mentioned by name the
buzz was still big enough that a slew of
books began to emerge about the
Wisconsin killer before long this
strange mummers boy had the sort of fame
usually reserved only for men who have
changed the world not turned their
neighbors into a matching set of tales
and chairs in the year 2000 someone
finally stole ed Gein's tombstone from
Plainfield cemetery as ironic as the
idea is it does get at something darker
as the heart of human nature our
fascination with the perpetrators of
awful acts by simply doing something
gruesome Dean managed to become famous
in a way that thousands of doctors
scientists and artists never will
at the point he became more famous than
his victims no one would ever Commission
write or watch a biographic of Mary
Hogan or Bernice worden but here we are
willing to talk to you about a man who
entered their lives on mass murderers
like Stalin and Hitler changed history
edn simply survived a terrible childhood
before turning all of that misery on
women that didn't deserve it by sheer
fluke he then became associated with
three horror movies that everybody
watching this has certainly heard of
maybe there's a lesson in his life that
we can learn a lesson about celebrity in
the way we ignore those who suffer in
favor of those that caused the suffering
or maybe there's just nothing to learn
here at all in this tale of perversion
but this one thing we can't deny the
butcher of Plainfield still exerts a
terrible hold over our imaginations and
in some ways ed Gein's ghost still
haunts us to this very day so I really
hope you found that video gonna say
horrific because that's what it was if
you're still watching at the ends here
well good for you that was brutal if you
did like it give it a thumbs up if you
didn't like it probably give it a thumbs
down do subscribe for more less brutal
stuff in the future and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]
you